that's gum resin resin right back
sichting on the toilet sitting on a
toilet sitting on a toilet now tell me
what are you doing on my toilet
everybody dance now hey get off my child
Steven Collins get off my child this is
not 7:00 heaven it looks like every time
they update this game you just have to
live by the fact that everything gets
deleted
Oh God I almost fell down this cliff I
need to wash off perfect here's a pond I
am walking in the water I always wanted
to be a submarine thanks thanks mom
thanks dad
why don't we can jump from that cliff
down there let's do that yes what a
great idea boots shut up you're an axe
I've got bunnies what are you going all
right where's the hole
oh no no are you serious are you [ __ ]
kidding me
where am I oh [ __ ] me what it's at my
Louboutin bag oh thanks and demon babies
I come in peace and demon babies demon
babies not a big deal Oh run demon
babies do something oh god I don't think
he sees it he tries to learn me in with
sexual noises your mating call will not
work on me sir
what would ma'am I have no food no water
no life literally I spend all day on
tumblr but we made it out of lab thank
God all right well it looks like we're
gonna have to set camp here breasts
random human on the beach let's make
sure he pays how's the weather
that's great hand I always wanted to
meet a rock hand they're quite rare
quite delicious - let's eat it what the
[ __ ] is this a turtle gangbang well
anything is possible in this game
choppity chopped up top cap chopped whoa
whoa that [ __ ] flew whoa am
well--we're everyone is excited this
morning I don't know what it is a nice
little butthole you got there thumbnail
nice 8b maybe he gave a shut up shot and
I'm tired of you I'm not gonna help you
anymore
Oh God he's calling his army of birds
seriously [ __ ] off from Shannon god
dammit Shannon stop calling the birds
Shannon sorry kids it's my super Pokemon
ability I can't help it I'm just too hot
all right well I'm bringing you to my
camp you're gonna have to go to rehab
chatted no gaming you I don't have a
problem it's a lifestyle it's not a
problem
go back beads you understand Shannon
you're my best oh Shannon makes me jump
now there's a motherboard of course
everyone knows you can find a
motherboard on the beach if you ever
want to find a motherboard you just go
to the beach and get one everyone is set
this is where we can Alpine treehouse
Jesus Christ how luxurious can you be
what the hell is it gazebo you can build
a [ __ ] gazebo why would I feel the
gazebo if you're if you're out looking
for your son in the forest you try to
survive and you're just like well [ __ ]
me I'm gonna build myself a gazebo
alright alright let's build a gazebo
right there woah now we can build a
bonfire that's pretty awesome let's
build a [ __ ] bonfire bonfire Check
Point in disguise bonfire I am eating my
eyes don't do that bonfire I am tired of
chopping down trees please do I really
have to chop down so many [ __ ] trees
I wish you could build a chainsaw that
would be [ __ ] amazing I don't know
how you build a chainsaw oh god what is
this what is this what do you doing this
is not how we chop down trees in Sweden
alright so now we have more energy we
can chop like a man she froze all right
well that's good that's my [ __ ] in my
[ __ ] only look at that but it's mine
forever
what the [ __ ] is your doing hand hand we
talked about this did it it did it did
it did it did it did it it it it it did
there we go let's let this [ __ ] up
that's a nice and cozy light did you see
that Shannon Shannon she passed out a
drunk son of a [ __ ] should we build the
gazebo Bros I feel like you boys want to
see a gazebo this will be the greatest
damn gazebo this town has ever known
what the [ __ ] are you
I can't chop you down here we go it's
morning oh god oh god we got haters they
won my gazebo well I guess II know all
right there we go so worth it it's so
nice in here oh my I'm loving it in here
I bet you're all jealous that you don't
have a gazebo yeah this is my gazebo and
you can't do anything about it come here
come here oh he dropped his teeth that's
cute oh you're still alive any last word
how about what the [ __ ] just oh you're
still there oh sorry I'm gonna kill you
I'll find become a but then see if I
care why does his hand have to do hand
hand hands
what are you doing hand I don't
understand and where are you going don't
worry about me [ __ ] I have a better
life ahead of me now thanks to you I'm
finally free hand
stop it hand you're being ridiculous
let's just let me be free damn it I'm
going I'm going and I'm never coming
back and you don't know what's best for
you you can't stop me Pierce you can't
I'm gonna miss that son-of-a-bitch
no one knew how to touch me like head
Lissie [ __ ] suicide Lizzy
what were they did they then walk they
walk into my fire
[ __ ] genius lazy [ __ ] genius ow ow
ah I did I take it back I'm so smart so
smart I'm a lizzy hater about a pudding
pie skater you came to the wrong herd
[ __ ] slap my [ __ ] sit down
where do they go oh hey whoa what
happened had I think hand blessed me
nice legs
have a great life hand uh-huh I'll never
forget you I love you I right hmm
I think you're ready Shannon I think
you're ready to return to your natural
habitat Thank You Pierce I owe you one
I left you know you don't Shannon oh
shut up Shannon you don't know what love
is
you're a hand oh my god it's my hand I
must follow the truth I sure what is
happening right what what is this is the
weirdest game ever what is good all
right Shannon I want you to follow hand
and I want you to never look back
keep going did hand change direction
what the [ __ ] I don't even know anymore
whatever kids just follow follow the
hand I get it all right you're free and
[ __ ] should I feel bad
yes but they dance so lovely that I
can't help myself haha nice little
natural thing you did there I I
appreciate it
I love my gazebo it is so lovely and
pretty
my gazebo is amazing all the haters
wants to still let they're so jealous
they won my gazebo the sons of [ __ ]
it's my [ __ ] gazebo and ain't nobody
touch it
that's this episode I hope you enjoyed
like favorite and subscribe see they're
after me I have to keep going say
awesome brooch Mahe